merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à monsieur jacques myard merci monsieur
président monsieur le ministre de la
ville
vous n'avez pas le monopole de la vie
associative et nous n'avons pas de
leçons à recevoir de vous en matière d'
aide
monsieur milices les affaires étrangères
lorient est compliqué nous le savons et
il est parfois difficile de lire et de
comprendre les tenants et aboutissants
de l'imbroglio géopolitique et
diplomatique qui règne mais il apparaît
aussi difficile de lire et de comprendre
votre politique étrangère dans cette
région explosive vouloir la chute du
régime de damas est une chose mais il
faut s'interroger sur les conséquences
de ce changement de régime pour la syrie
et les syriens et le liban il faut
surtout s'interroger sur les alliances
que l'on nous à cette fin jusqu'à
présent vous nous présentiez l'armée
syrienne libre asl comme le seul vecteur
la seule force démocratique contre damas
il est vrai que la sl étaient peu
représentés dans les salons des hôtels
internationaux que sur le terrain or
depuis quelques semaines en suivant les
américains
l'arabie saoudite le qatar et la turquie
la france pour faire tomber le régime de
damas et pour lutter contre l'état
islamique fait le choix de soutenir al
nowshera mouvements terroristes affiliés
à al qaïda il est vrai que pour se faire
une virginité ce mouvement ne sera
changé de nom et s'appelle jack al fath
l'armée de la conquête son chef mohammed
ali giulani explique sur al jazeera
qu'après la victoire et l'appliquerait
la charia en syrie voilà une annonce qui
va combler la joie de toutes les
mobilités minorités religieuses dont les
chrétiens d'orient et hier une requête
syrienne est tombé sur le lycée français
où les enfants passaient le brevet
monsieur le ministre votre politique
obsessionnel de faire tomber la masse
qui aura pour conséquence d'installer
el-qaïda à damas traduit en évidence une
habileté diplomatique consommer monsieur
le ministre quand allez vous cesser de
suivre ces génies de la géopolitique que
sont les américains
saoudien qui joue les apprentis sorciers
et met le feu au proche orient
la parole est à monsieur le ministre des
affaires étrangères c'est le début des
bières d'abord je voudrais vous
remercier de votre question comme
d'habitude tout en nuances
non ensuite sur le fond sur le fond vous
nous expliquer depuis déjà pas mal de
moi que si l'on veut trouver une
solution en syrie il faut soutenir le
régime de monsieur bachar el assad non
seulement d'un point de vue moral nous
en sommes déjà expliqué ce serait une
infamie
car ce n'est pas parce qu'on reçoit des
journalistes en costume-cravate qu'on
élimine le sens qu'on a sur les mains
mais d'autre part sur le plan de la
seule efficacité il faut bien comprendre
que monsieur bachar el-assad et les
terroristes on vous avait parlé c'est
l'avers et le revers d'une même médaille
il n'y a qu'une solution c'est la
recherche de la paix et la recherche de
la paix passe par une solution politique
qui veut dire d'une part le soutien à
l'opposition non pas l'opposition
terroristes mais à l'opposition qui
accepte que toutes les communautés
soient présentes en syrie et d'autre
part monsieur myard le soutient une
solution avec l'opposition et des
éléments du régime
je le dis clairement sans monsieur
bachar el-assad c'est ce dont nous
discutons avec les arabes avec les
américains et je vais vous faire plaisir
monsieur myard avec les russes et c'est
la seule façon dont nous pouvons avancer
vous critiquer la politique de la france
elle n'a qu'un objectif rechercher la
paix et la recherche de la paix monsieur
bien ça n'est jamais une erreur